Input processor provides three call
backs for dealing with touches and
clicks.
Touches and clicks are actually
handled in the same way and
are just referred to as touches.
Actually, this program I'm drawing
on uses a very similar system
to determine when to draw the lines.
For instance,
as my pen touches this screen,
a touched down signal is received.
That means it's time to
start drawing a line.
As I move the pen the program is
continually receiving touch dragged
notifications, meaning that it's time
to draw a little bit more of the line.
Finally, when I reach the end
of my line and I remove the pen,
there's a touch up call that says
alright stop drawing the line now.
Note that the touch or click coordinates
provided in these call backs
is always provided in terms
of screen coordinates.
If you want to get the position of
a touch in your world coordinates,
you will need to convert from
screen to world coordinates.
Let's check out how to do that.